welcome back to a20 special relativity
in this last example of relativistic
kinematics we want to investigate
scattering in the specific cases
scattering of a photon on an electron at
rest
so we have as an initial state a photon
an electron at rest
and then the photon is scattered and we
also observe a scattered electron
there is one important piece of physics
here which we add without further
explanation which is the planck einstein
relation which relates the energy of the
photon to the frequency of the photon or
the wavelength
this is
fundamentally important in
quantum physics
and
can be explained or tested with the
photoelectric effect for which einstein
received the nobel prize
so what we want to do here is find the
wavelength shift so delta lambda
which is the wavelength of the incoming
photon minus the wavelength of the
outgoing photon
as a function of the scattering angle
theta as shown in this picture here
okay so again this is an activity i want
you to to to work on and and try to find
out this the algebra here is not trivial
but knowing how to set up a problem like
this is important
so let's try
so
the way to set this up is to write this
four vector relation or you could just
simply write down energy conservation
and momentum conservation so you have an
initial state the before
and the final state the after so you
simply add the four vectors of the
initial electron and photon
um and set this equal to the scattered
electron and the scattered folder
now we are interested in
a quantity delta lambda which is related
to the change in energy of the photon
so therefore you bring the four vector
of the four scattered photon over here
to this side
um and build the square which allows us
then to use
our invariant information in this within
the scattering process
um
when we explore the squared here
um we find the photon for vectors
squared
um for the scattered and the unscattered
photon minus two times the product of
the two four vectors now the mass of the
photon is zero and then hence the
invariant mass is zero two so this
invariant four vector
is zero so this cancels and this cancels
and then we know that the mass of the
electron is the mass of the electron the
initial momentum of the electron is zero
and we just for the further not to get
confused we set c equal to 0 to 1.
so then we just go through a sequence of
algebra here
making use of
information that those guys here are
simply the mass of the electron um we
move things around a little bit and then
find this equation here which relates
um the the energies of the two photons
we are the scattering angle which we get
from the scalar product of the
three momenta of the photon
to the change in electron
energy
which is the energy of the electron
minus the mass
okay and then we start using the
einstein relation here
and again a little bit of algebra then
brings us to delta lambda equal
h over me times 1 minus cosine theta
so this relates the
shift in wavelength to the scattering
angle of the photon
important if you want to recall this
the most important part to this problem
is setting up
this first equation here which relates
the energy and the momentum or the four
vector of those particles before and
after the collision
and again and then you know it takes a
little bit of practice but the way to
approach most of those problems is to
make use of
um the invariant for vector
squared
or the invariant mass of the objects
involved as we know the masses of the
object involved
okay
you